yeah oh it's gone firmer
okay so just watches or two waters
yeah good luck I look like a homeless
Blake Lively right now so I just got to
my hotel in San Francisco if I didn't
tell you why I'm in San Francisco stop
stalking me I'm in San Francisco because
there is a panel that I'm doing for Fast
Company magazine tomorrow and I'm
excited because it's a panel about
YouTube and Ingrid missglamorazzi and
the guys from Boise Avenue are all in
the panel and they're all lovely humans
that I don't spend time with ever so
hopefully I'll get a chance to have like
human-being conversations tomorrow with
them it is almost 8 o'clock mamrie and I
are supposed to Skype so that we can go
over stuff for our shows this weekend
you haven't bought your tickets yet
jesus [ __ ] christ just by your
goddamn tickets for this might get weird
y'all it won't get weird unless you're
there that was a six hour flight and it
just felt so long so I'm gonna go jog
for a little bit in the fitness center
just thrilling homeless Blake Lively
just thrilling
all right sorry
Motown Pandora station don't my muse
means for skiers I'm getting ready to go
to the Fast Company event really fun to
put the phrase sophisticated as a sham
Fast Company in the same sentence you're
welcome here's a demonstration on
utilizing social media to build a brand
that is authentic and genuine I went to
Target yesterday to pick up some stuff
that I forgot to bring with me ie a
curling iron I don't wake up like this
no I don't and I ended up getting a um
this a full on blue on blue sweater on
skirt ensemble booty dee my OOTD feeling
very Monica Lewinsky only they started
the color not based on like morals
oh my god when I love to take video in
the actual of the theater there's a new
photos this is video alright about this
the Elephant Man examines I know you I
wonder
you can tell how excited you are by the
octave of your voice I I think I realize
I saw I'll kick you answer my pocket and
I was like oh I saw you guys and your
instinct was to go directly your phone
and record they literally just had
dinner like under 10 minutes ago
polite KitKat's
hello it is Thursday night is it yes
walking on the Highland and it's raining
it is cold
oh look it's a standoff camera
the moment we're headed to Nashville
we're very excited
dog in a bookstore dog in a bookstore
don't get in a book start
good morning it's Saturday morning and
it's a day of our first does make it
weird y'all show that mamrie and I are
doing here in Nashville and like most
shows that we put together I am writing
my bits all right no no we were up late
last night to like at least midnight
going over show ideas which it's weird
because today or shows at 1:00 p.m. in
the afternoon and usually they're at
night at 7 or 8 so usually the day of
the show we have all day to scramble and
get all the last-minute things we need
and we don't really have that today you
get this Saturday ready this week and
this vase guys have been working my
impressions this is Marlon Brando this
is Jack Nelson
so mr. Swann I was near one of those
fish that suck on the walls of the fish
tank more fun stuff like that in our
live shows make sure you buy your
tickets now okay we're backstage getting
we stop so much to do before the show
happens that's happening it's all
happening the show to plan yeah yeah so
sorry in advance Nashville we just got
to the airport and let go we found a
video diary I'm in a cab right now we
made it to Charlotte yay
Mary Shire says I think Nick Nick is our
tech guy on this tour which is super fun
cos Nick and I went to college yeah the
so many men who a college higher
education we just did a show in
Nashville which was so much fun and also
really jarring to do a show at one
o'clock in the afternoon and then after
the show get on a plane and land in
Charlotte and then we do a show in
toilet tomorrow so we're going to a
hotel I'm just watching you she's made
it to the hotel and Charlotte look
beautiful
Charlotte you look like a hotel room
interesting choice
so I'm so excited that the this make it
weird y'all tours kicked off really well
the show chair was so much fun
it was so stupid who's so stupid or
excited she the rest of the dates if you
haven't bought tickets yet please do
we're going to Houston and Tempe and
Atlanta I am exhausted it's 10:30 10:40
something like that I'm going to edit a
video and just really reflect nope not
gonna do that at all probably gonna
order more room service yeah I don't
know I didn't know they were in my
pocket like a second ago and then I
realized they were and like it's a great
moment